[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the family of a black jogger sues his
alleged killers one year after his death
the investigation litigation and reforms
in the ahmad armory case
the independent investigation into the
death of elijah mclean
the report finding police officers had
no justification to stop the 23 year old
an inside look into the use of force and
the powerful injection
a nazi concentration guard living in the
u.s for half a century
now deported to germany plus the lengths
one deputy took
to save a missing girl the rescue caught
on body cam video
just waiting there for me are you okay
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
it's been one year since three white men
chased down and killed
a young black man in a georgia
neighborhood the killing shocked the
nation
leading to reforms in the peach state
and murder charges against those men
i think that this case is as much a
watershed
moment so to speak as the george floyd
case
the case was different but just as
startling in georgia three white men
chased down a young
unarmed black man in a neighborhood
claiming a mod arbory was breaking into
a house
on february 23 2020. there were
civilians involved
who assumed that they were asked acting
as police officers
the local prosecutors said at the time
that no charges would be filed
in may the attorney for one of the
suspects shared video of the shooting
with the media
then the georgia bureau investigation
was assigned to the case
once the georgia bureau of investigation
became involved in that case within a
36-38 hour time
frame we had warrants issued for the
arrest of two individuals
we conducted the remainder of our
investigation before we
made the decision that probable cause
existed to arrest the third defendant we
did that
the suspects father gregory mcmichael
son travis mcmichael
and neighbor william rhodey bryant all
three would be arrested for felony
murder
and later indicted on malice murder
aggravated assault and false
imprisonment
as it turned out gregory mcmichael
retired just a year earlier
after working as an investigator for the
district attorney's office for 24 years
you know i was chief investigator with
the da's office
for 23 years so i know what you got to
do i know everything
you know the gbi revealed that aubrey
went jogging in the attila shores
neighborhood of brunswick
surveillance video taken from a home
under construction shows aubry going
inside and drinking water
video taken by brian minutes later
captured the three men
chasing after aubry aubry appears to try
to run around the truck
when he is shot by travis mcmichael i
live right there
we've had break-ins okay and my gun's
stolen
okay and uh we caught him the other day
and my dad was outside and saw him
running
running by and neighbors pointing and
everything coming out of the truck
running at us
i told him stop stop stop till he hit me
i had nothing to do
hey the men claimed self-defense
but prosecutors say the crime was
racially motivated citing racist texts
found on their phones
and statements made about the shooting
mr bryan said that
after the shooting took place before
police arrival
while mr aubry was on the ground
that he heard travis michael make the
statement
since the shooting georgia added a hate
crime law to its books
one of four states in the country
without it now the governor is trying to
eliminate a civil war-era citizen's
arrest law
ahmad was a victim of vigilante style of
violence that has no place in georgia
and some tried to justify the actions of
his killers by claiming they had the
protection of an antiquated law that is
right for abuse
for iman aubrey's family justice means
keeping his memory alive
as the nation's reckoning over race
intensifies
he ran this path
many times
and our home was just a light jog away
but for him no matter how he maneuvered
no matter how he how fast he ran
or how quickly he turned these men
refused to let him go home
they should not go home now this
incident actually occurred
before the untimely death of george
floyd
and it too received uh tremendous
national
attention and i think piggybacking on
that
the incident involving george floyd was
basically the straw
that broke the camel's back so this case
and everything that surrounds it
actually cast a much wider net as far as
the tensions racial tensions and so
forth
in this country here to look back on the
life and legacy
of a mod arbory and the reforms that
followed is civil rights attorney dewitt
lacy and terry austin
do it a year after aubry was killed by
travis mcmichael lee merritt the
family's attorney
filed a federal lawsuit claiming there
was a cover-up by the glenn county
police department
thoughts on that lawsuit
well brian i'll tell you you know
the lawsuit is it's got some issues it's
going to be tough
because these folks are uh the
mcmichaels
are going to be need to be thought of
under the law's eyes as
acting under the color of law however of
course
they weren't officers the lawsuit
alleges they were deputized
there seems to be some factual
information to suggest that
some law enforcement officers uh sought
to advise community members
uh that they could refer to the
mcmichaels
and when they were in need of law
enforcement help
so i mean there's some struggles there
but i think that it gets at some very
significant issues in law enforcement in
georgia
now terry as you saw there governor kemp
is currently trying to reform the law of
citizens arrest
along with routes to the year after the
emancipation proclamation
allowing citizens to arrest fleeing
criminals how will this create change in
georgia
well let's hope that it does the old law
is antiquated and it really allowed for
vigilantism
the new law is going to make it more
than just suspicion under the old law if
you suspect that there was a crime
almost anybody could make an arrest now
under the new law
you can still defend yourself you can
defend your home and if a business
person sees that a crime is being
committed
then they can make an arrest and of
course police can still make an arrest
if they have probable cause but what the
new law
is attempting to do is to limit the
circumstances
where these arrests can be made let's
see how that law is actually
enforced when it's actually passed it's
devastating that a life
had to be lost to create change but may
aubrey's legacy forever changed georgia
for the better
do it terry thank you for your input
still ahead on law and crime daily
did wisconsin man kill his wife to be
with his new girlfriend
but first we break down the independent
probe into the death of elijah mclean
why investigators are criticizing first
responders handling of the case
[Music]
next
[Music]
an independent investigation into the
death of elijah mcclain in police
custody found fault
with the officers he's encountered that
night and the department's handling of
the case
law on crime's angela levy is here with
the report's finding
yeah brian the city of aurora their city
council actually asked for this
independent review it found that police
didn't even have constitutional grounds
to stop
elijah mclean and that the police use of
force investigation was deeply flawed
stop right there hey stop right there
stop stop stop i have a right to stop
you because you're being suspicious
that's body camera video from the
initial contact police had with elijah
mclean on august 24
2019. it is important to note that
neither the caller
nor any of the officers identified a
crime that they thought mr mclean had
committed
was committing or was about to commit
the investigation found that even that
initial contact was flawed the officer
must
under the federal constitution and
colorado law a reasonable suspicion
that the person had committed a crime is
committing a crime
or is about to commit a crime the
investigation also found that the major
crimes division made errors when
interviewing the officers involved
such as not questioning them about why
they made the leap from approaching
mclean in a voluntary stop
to then investigating him for a crime
they had no knowledge of
and then making an arrest
police placed mclean in a neck hole that
cut off blood to his brain
leaving him unconscious and paramedics
injected mclean with a sedative
independent investigators also faulted
officers for using pain compliance
techniques
despite mclean being cuffed and then
police investigators not pressing the
officers about that force
he did not have supernatural strength as
you can see from the video
he is completely restrained under a pile
of law enforcement officers
that was one of the lawyers from
mclean's family last year the family has
filed a wrongful death lawsuit
maclean's mother released a statement
after the independent investigation's
findings were revealed
it reads in part missionine mclean is
relieved that the truth surrounding the
death of her son is finally coming to
light
we applaud the independent review
panel's objectives studious and
comprehensive investigation
into the events of august 24 2019.
now the review actually applauded the
aurora police department for a few
things including
banning those carotid choke holds after
elijah mcclain's death they also
implemented a policy that enables
officers to stop use of force
either physically or verbally and there
was also some fault found with the
district attorney's review of this case
their investigation or lack thereof
the colorado attorney general has
actually empaneled a grand jury to
investigate mclean's death brian
thanks angenet here to break down the
death of elijah mclean and civil rights
attorney dwight lacy and terry austin
terry in the report the doctors said
that mclean's health was already
declining
and a more even a more accurate dosage
of ketamine would not have changed the
outcome
that sounds like to me at least based on
my defense attorney background
that that could have been manslaughter
or murder so what do you think's gonna
happen with a grand jury
you know that's a good question brian in
my opinion i think both the police
and the emt should be held accountable
and i think charges
should be brought you heard from
angenette's report
that we did not see the police here
telling him why he was being stopped
what was suspicious about his behavior
was he committing a crime and then we
hear
also that once he's down he gets
shot with ketamine and 500 milligrams
which is the maximum amount and so i
think
that both the officers and the emt
should be held accountable for this and
i think it's wonderful that we have
policies
in place now that this has occurred but
i think we need to have specific
accountabilities for these actions
yeah policy is one thing justice is
another to it we covered this
story when it first came out i want to
read you a quote that the report came up
with
when talking about the aurora pd asking
leading questions
they said the officers elicited quote
specific exonerating
magic language found in court rulings to
me that sounds like the investigators
led the officers to the right answers to
get them off what are your thoughts
uh that is textbook brian for how
these officer involved uh investigation
officer
officer involved shootings and or death
investigations go
especially in civil rights cases we see
it all the time there's kind of a nudge
nudge and a wink wink here
about answers uh and then these answers
are suggested
uh to the person who's being
investigated
and sadly that's a pretty par for the
course
uh throughout uh uh investigations of
officers uh who have killed people uh
so i i think you're right uh yes it
definitely suggests that
there's some type of shoddy
investigation or at least some
complicity
in law enforcement killing people when
they shouldn't yeah
and anger with all of the criticisms
that came out of the investigation
is the city planning to do anything else
yeah you know they are brian the city
manager actually just announced that
they are going to be
setting up or implementing an
independent monitor
to oversee the police department in
these use of force issues
they hope that that will increase the
amount of accountability
the police department has to the public
and they have also discontinued the fire
department has with the paramedics the
use of
ketamine you also um terry mentioned
earlier that
although that didn't contribute to
elijah mcclain's death according to the
review they found that
he was already in distress at the time
but they have discontinued the use of
that sedative
all right well we'll see where those
policies changes go but policy without
punishment doesn't really change much
from what i've seen thank you everyone
coming up on law on crime daily a
naughty concentration guard caught right
here in america
now deported to germany plus why would
an elderly man bring a gun into the
office of his apartment complex
a sneak preview into the hit new hit
series i survived a crime
[Music]
next
we're back when a 93 year old man
brought a gun into a las vegas office
employees were terrified about what he
might do host of the news show i
survived the crime gio benitez is here
to tell us their story
the cranky old man stereotype can often
elicit laughs but what happened to our
next survivor
at the hands of an irate elderly man is
far from funny
an unexpected encounter almost cost him
his life
las vegas nevada it's 9 10 am
an elderly man walks into an apartment
management office
to complain about his flooded apartment
a female office worker is behind the
desk
her supervisor is nearby the elderly man
is irate and threatens them
the woman discreetly presses a panic
button beneath her desk
and dials 9-1-1 9-1-1 emergency
tracing 4804 fire or medical
please please we have a man with guns
is he in the office yes is he
threatening anyone with the gun
yes he has it out in his hand yes
the man fires around it rips through a
computer
please sir stop please please
the woman begs for her life no please
stop
no i have grandbabies i have kids i have
to take i have kids i have to take care
of
please don't hurt him either please
okay ma'am we've got officers who are
going to be on the way is there any way
that you can get out of the office and
leave him there
i can try try and get out of the office
if you can safely do so
okay
the man allows her to go but holds her
colleague at gunpoint
he orders him to stay seated then he
takes aim
tell me about that video break that down
what else are we going to hear about
that
crazy bit of video when we tune into
your show
well he does shoot and in fact if you've
been seeing the promo
of the show we show that moment where he
does shoot now he shoots him in his leg
so he doesn't kill the man and so
thankfully that man
does survive but this is a very very
scary situation
and what's unique about this is that you
have the surveillance video
they're recording but you also have the
woman on the phone with 9-1-1
that's how you're able to hear the audio
so you are really
transported right into that room because
you hear
what is happening in that room at that
exact moment while you're watching
shocking story i survived the crime airs
wednesdays at 9 00 pm on the a e
networks
when we come back the lengths one deputy
went through to rescue a missing teen
the body cam video and harrowing story
you don't want to miss
after the break
prosecutors in wisconsin are continuing
to present their case
alleging a husband killed his wife and
hid her body
james procopovich is charged with first
degree intentional homicide of his wife
of 24 years
victoria prokopovic investigators say it
was part of his plan
to be with his new girlfriend catherine
friday the defense claims the victim
suffered from mental health illnesses
and calls her disappearance a suicide
prosecutors expect to wrap up their case
on wednesday
the defense could present evidence on
thursday
a 95 year old former nazi concentration
camp guard
has been deported from tennessee to
germany the department of justice says
carl frederick berger
arrived in frankfort after a u.s
immigration judge ordered his removal
last year the judge found burger
willingly served as an
armed guard in a concentration camp
during a two-day trial
burger said he did not observe any
killings the court however
ruled berger participated in a forced
evacuation during the winter of 1945.
70 prisoners died during the two-week
ordeal burger had been living in the u.s
since 1959. he reportedly has agreed to
be questioned by german prosecutors
the wife of the infamous drug kingpin
joaquin el chapo guzman
has been arrested on international drug
trafficking charges
fbi agents took emma carnell ispiro into
custody at dual's international airport
in virginia on monday afternoon she's
accused of helping el chapo escape from
a mexican prison and evade capture
she's also accused of helping to
coordinate shipments of cocaine
heroin marijuana and methamphetamine
cornell was born in california and is a
dual citizen of the u.s and mexico
el chapo is currently in federal custody
serving a life sentence
a sheriff's deputy is being hailed as a
hero for rescuing a missing 13-year-old
girl
the volusia county sheriff's office says
the girl ran away with a 22 year old man
she met online the girl's grandmother
said she didn't return home
and her friend told investigators she
was picked up at a dollar store by the
man
deputy royce james tirelessly went to
local motels seeing if the teen was
there
at the third hotel he found a match oh
where's this guy i think this is him
front office anybody inside we need to
come in for a second
sheriff's office back up have a seat on
the couch
just waiting here for me are you okay
do you need me are you hurt at all
you're not hurt at all your stomach
hurts okay we're gonna be right with you
okay
how do you
if i ask you that question again i'm
gonna lose my mind how old are you
oh you fucked up yeah you felt real good
tyler thompson was arrested and is
facing charges of interference with
child custody
and traveling to meet after using a
computer to lure a child
he was released from jail on a fifteen
thousand dollar bail
additional charges are pending here to
discuss
probably every parent's nightmare is
dewitt lacy and terry austin
scary reality for this family but
thankfully she is safe and the video
capturing
a great detective at work
do what what's your reaction
uh wow now this officer certainly
deserves
all the praise and accommodation that he
should get i mean
excellent work for him and diligent uh
to continue searching for this young
girl
uh when he didn't have to you know but
he certainly
uh did his work uh and and
did what he needed to do in order to
make sure that this young girl got
brought home safely
and kudos to him and the department for
having uh such a person of fine
character
and dedication to the service now tara
what stuck out to you when you saw this
video
brian i actually was moved to tears when
i saw her run up to
the officer and hug him you know thank
god for deputy
you know james he actually followed up
on
information he did not stop he went
door to door until he finally found her
so
kudos to him all right thank you for
joining us here at long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you